ve
sanıyorum 14 yaşındaydım Ortaokulda veya
liselim tam net hatırlamıyorum ama şunu
hatırlıyorum Tabii ki bir atlet Team Bir
sporcu Yudum ve 400 metre engelli
branşında yarışıyorum çok Alışık olduğum
bir branş değildi Bir yandan ama okullar
arası bir turnuva vardı ve 400 metre
engelli yarışı konuşacaktım ondan sonra
tam böyle yarışı oturdum takoz oturdum
yarışma başladı ve heyecanlıyım birazcık
falan koşuyorum ilk engel yaklaştım ilk
engeli geçtim ikinci ele engelle
yaklaştım Ondan sonra bir baktım bir
anda bulutları gökyüzünü görüyorum
adresinden yüzün tabi çok fark etmemiş
Ama ben onu Ben de düşmüştüm tekrar
kalktım devam ettim 3. engelle doğru
ilerledim orada engelli geçtim sanarken
bir daha düştüm bu sefer artık
düştüğünün farkındaydım ikinci kere
düşmüştüm Çünkü ve hiçbir zaman da
aklımın ucundan yarışı bırakmak geçmedi
bir şekilde kafamın İçindeki ses bana
devam et bitiş çizgisine doğru gitti
oldu çünkü o zaman tabi spora İnanılmaz
seviyorum Olimpiyatları izliyorum
atletizm yarışmalarını izliyorum oradaki
sporcuları görüyorum bazen sakatlanıyor
ama yarışı bitiriyorlar alkışları
alıyorlar Benim için de o noktada en
önemli şey yarışı bitirmek Tea Tabii çok
iddiam yoktu zaten yarışın başında da
sonunda da iki kez düştükten sonra artık
tabii ki bir 400 metre gibi kısa bir
yarışı kazanıyorsunuz ama ben bir
şekilde o yarışı bitirdim sonra
arkadaşlarının yanına gittim takım
arkadaşlarımın ve bana daha önce geçmiş
olsun falan dediler ve biraz da hayal
kırıklığı yaşadılar Onlar da iyi
konuşmadı bu gördükleri içine bakayım
sana dizini tam olarak bilemiyordu bu
koşu benim için çok uzun bir süre bir
utanç kaynağı halindeydi onu böyle
belinde uzaklaştırmaya çalışıyorum
Düşünmemeye çalışıyorum gece böyle
Platon böyle uykuya dalma esnasında
böyle akıllı yıllar öncesine ait çok
utanç verici çok kötü bir anı gelir ya
böyle sürekli bu yarış benim beynime
gelip gelip duruyor bir şekilde
uzaklaştırdım hayatıma devam ettim
atletizme da devam ettim lise sona kadar
işte artık üniversiteye hazırlanırken
atletizmi bıraktım ama bir yandan da çok
fazla etkinlik yapan bir öğrenciydim bir
yandan işte konuda şarkı söylüyorum Bir
yandan bir kulüp etkinliğinde gazete
çıkartıyorum bir yandan şiir dinletileri
düzenliyorum kitap okuyorum böyle bir
this hayatı getirmiştim ve bu yarısını
Aslında benim karakterim ile ilgili çok
önemli şeyler söyleyeceğini hiç o zaman
ihtimal vermemiştim hakkında bu
uzaklaştırır bu ay boyunca bir şekilde
geri döndü aklıma bu uyarır bir yandan
da bu kadar çok yönlü bir insanım sporda
çok iddiam yok Kendi sporcu olmayacağımı
biliyorum okuyandan içimde böyle bir
gazetecilik ateşi var bir Gazeteci olmak
istiyorum yayıncı olmak istiyorum zaten
konuşmayı çok seven bir insanın kendini
ifade etmeyi çok seven bir insanım Bu
yüzden bu kalıcı olacağım' yayıncı
olacağım diye düşünüyorum ve
Üniversitede hangi okula gireceğimi
biliyorum üniversite sınavında çalıştım
hazırlandım ve o okula girdim Hatta o
üniversite radyosunda çok dinliyordum
küçükken ve lisedeyken baba şöyle
söylediğini hatırlıyorum bunu bak birkaç
sene ben buraya gireceğim burada yayın
yapacağım diyordum ya bunu gerçekten
başardım üniversite türü ikinci hatta
üniversite bir sınıftaydım Yanılmıyorsam
ve öğrenci ve girdim Orada yayın yapmaya
başladım Daha sonra tabii ki Yayıncılık
Bir kere insanın kanına girince tekrar
çıkması çok zor oluyor ki benim gibi
insan için özellikle Daha sonra bir
televizyon kanalında staja başladım
Hatta bir televizyon kanalının spor Ser
bu yayına başladım hem tutkulu olduğumuz
sporu bir yandan içindeyim Hem bir
yandan yayın yapıyorum benim için çok
güzel bir hayat cennet gibi bir şey
değil zannediyorum tabii ki o ayar O
zaman çok az para kazanıyorum bir yandan
öğrenciyim bir yandan okuyorum falan ama
bunların hiçbiri benim için önemli
değildi Ben bir şekilde istediğim bir
şey yapmak için devam ettim ve
üniversitedeyken bir anlamda başka İşler
de iyi başka şeyler yapıyorum sosyal
hayatı Max atmamaya çalışıyorum yine çok
yoğun bir hayatın var mezun olma
yaklaştığımızda arkadaşlarım Tabii ki
planlarını yapmaya başladı artık işte
mezun olunca ne yapacağız çalışacak
mıyız ne yapacaksın Ben diyorum ki ben
biliyorum ne yapacağımı zaten ben bu işi
yapıyorum Ve bu işi yapmaya devam
edeceğim sürekli ne istediğini bilen o
çizgiye doğru koşan bir insan var yani
Bak atlı mezun oldum birkaç ay geçti tam
böyle Eylül ayıydı doğum günümdü ve bir
anda
işten
çıkarıldığını öğrendim ve bunun için bu
gerekçe hiçbir neden sunulmamış tı bana
Aslında daha Tabii ki düşündüğüm zaman
bir neden bulabiliyorum Çünkü orada bir
yönetici vardı ve o işlerindeki
kadınlarla kızlarla çok fazla
ilgileniyordu ve ben de bunu kabul
edemeyeceğimi o zaman söylemiştim ve
etrafta da konuşmuştum bunu nasıl Nasıl
böyle bir durumda kala bildiğiniz
anlamadığımı söylemiştim sanıyorum
sebebi buydu bunu hiçbir zaman Tabi ki
kanıtlama dım ama böyle olduğunu
düşünüyorum Daha sonra tabii ki 22
yaşındayım en sevdiğim işte yaparken bir
anda sebepsiz yere Ben hiçbir şey Issız
Kaldım ve bunun bir her zaman ne
istediğini bilen birisi olarak bir B
planı ve C planı yapmamıştım
Hatta işte yirmi yaşındayken ilk Ekrana
çıktığımdan bir görüntü bu daha böyle
çok geldim çok mutluyum yaptığım işi mi
yazdı masum böyle bir
zaman dilimi de çok mutluyum çalışırken
fakat bir anda ortada kaldım da bu su
Başka işler denedim
çalıştığım başka yerlerde çalışma içinde
o Yayıncılık her zaman vardı bu yaklaşık
bir buçuk sene sonra kendimi yeniden bir
televizyon kanalında buldum en önemli
spor kanalında yaydım ve yine ben Spor
yayınları yapmaya başlamıştım bu defa
birazcık daha ne istediğimi biliyordum
ve önüme çıkan ilk engelli de açtığımı
düşünüyordum ve artık işte biraz daha
tecrübeliyim Yaşım biraz daha büyük ve
daha fazla yayınlar yapmaya başladım
programlar sunuyorum işte haber
bültenlerinde yer alıyorum ama bir
yandan içinde şöyle bir ses var ya
bunlar tam olarak yeterli mi Çünkü Evet
Saçım yapılıyor makyajımı yapılıyor Ben
yayına çıkıyorum haberleri sunuyorum
programları sunuyorum elimden geleni
yapıyorum bütün spor müsabakalarını
İzliyorum zaten çok tutkuluyum yaptığım
ise hiçbir şey önemli değil benimsin
Sadece İş önemli ve şunu fark ettim
erkek meslektaşlarım program suyu haber
sunuyor Ama bir yandanda spor müsabakası
anlatıyor bu ama benden böyle bir
beklenti yok etrafa bakıyorum hiçbir
kadın meslektaşım bir spor müsabakası
anlatmıyor ve aklımın ucundan bile
geçmiyor kimsenin ve bir Ama şunu
düşündüm ben de ben anlatmıyorum ya
Tabii ki bu sorun birçok cevabı var
Bunlardan bir tanesi önümde hiç bir
örnek olmaması Çünkü insanlar spor
izlerken bir erkek sesi duymaya çok
alışkın ve buna devam etmek istiyor Bir
Kadın sesini bir spor müsabakasının
kafasına eşleştirmiyor Çünkü hiç
duymamış Yaklaşık 15 yıldır böyle birşey
yapılmamıştı Türkiye'de Ama tabii ki
benim aklıma bir kere düştüm bu Ben bunu
kovalamaya başladım artık ve
spiker eğitimlerinde
3 bölüm vardı bir tanesi işte maçta
program sunumu hava diksiyon ve maç
anlatımı ders vardı o zaman çalıştım
kanalda Siz diksiyona girdim haber
sunumuna program sunumuna girdim amaç
anlatımına girecek miyim Aslında tabii
ki kadın spikerler giremez diye yazıyor
Tabii ki aslında bu hem gerekiyor ama
yine de emin olmamıştım o dönemde ve
gidip sormuştum Hani ben buraya girmek
istiyorum girebilir miyim diye ama ben
bir sorayım fazla kimsenin aklından
geçmemişti bu ya Bir kadın spikerin
gelip maç anlatımında çalışacağım ama
işte futbol tampon altına girmek mi
istiyorsun falan gibi şeylerle
karşılaşma ve tüm ya bu tarz Sonuçta ben
bu derse girmek istiyorum Sonra işte
girdim Tabii ki bir şekilde böyle bir
kural olmadığı için ve orada Tabii ki
yaklaşık yirmi erkek var Ben vs12 kadın
meslektaşım daha varız ve Çünkü böyle
şeyler söyleniyor işte Yani tabii futar
kez burada kariyerinde ilerlemek
istiyordu derbi anlatmak istiyor
Şampiyonlar Ligi'ne anlatmak istiyoruz
Tabii aramızda kadın spiker
arkadaşlarımız var onlarda isterlerse
işte jimnastik çok yakışıklı Salah liste
voleybol Neden olmasın ki bir şey şeyler
söylüyorlardı Ve tabii ki
ben bunlara karşı çıktı benden bir spor
spikeri O benim işim maç anlatmak
olabilir haber sunmak olabilir program
sunmak alabilir röportaj yapmak olabilir
ve yetenek olarak ve meslek aşkı olarak
kendimi kimseden eksik görmüyorum Sadece
sesin kadın sesi olduğu için neden bu
işi yapamayız diye düşündüm ve ondan
sonra tabii ki bunu dile getirmeye
başladım sesli olarak işte
yöneticilerine söylüyorum spiker
büyüklerime söylüyorum ve bir şekilde
kendi Uzmanlık alanım olan atletizm
yayınlarıyla anlatım yapmaya başladım
hatta çok iyi hatırlıyorum anlatım
yapmaya için işte ilk kez bana bir
fırsat verin tamam dediler yarın size
geleceksin
atletizm yarışması anlatacaksın ben
sonra bu oynanmaz heyecanlandım Çok
mutlu oldum O Zaman Ki yöneticime
gitmiştim teşekkür etmek için yani Çok
teşekkür ederim bana güvendiniz böyle
bir yayın verdiğiniz demiştim ve
karşılaşıyor bir şey söylemiştin Evet o
yayın yapacaksın ama sana bunun
karşılığında ekstra bir yayın yazacağım
demişti Ve Şok olmuştum gerçekten yani
Ben zaten bu işi yapmak bu saatler
acıyorum ki bu zaten benim de işim
olmalı ve bunu bir lütufmuş gibi bana
soruluyor Aslında Fakat tabii ki ben
yayınlarımı yapmaya devam ettim ve
hayatımı değiştiren bir olay oldu bir
gün Ağustos ayında 2016 yılında
Olimpiyat Oyunları başlamak üzere Bu
Gece başlıyor Yani aslında tuşlarını o
akşam ve bazı müsabakalar çoktan
başlamış ve Türkiye'de bu Olimpiyatların
yayıncısı yok Ben de tabii ki hiç yani
yayıncısı yokken ne yapacağız bilmiyorum
bir anda ben de sosyal medyada gördükçe
bizim kanal olimpiyat oyunlarının
yayında Satın almış ve biz
yayınlayacağız Ben burada Acaba böyle
alabilir miyim kendime bir yer bulabilir
miyim diye düşünürken işte herhalde
olmaz diye düşünüyorum şimdi dışarı
çıkmak da Bugün arkadaşlarımla buluştum
falan eve döndüm saat gece 12.00 1.00
gibi böyle Olimpiyatları açılış töreni
izlerken mesaj geldi arkası gün yayınımı
olduğuna dair bir mesajdı ve Ve tabiki
20'den zıpla ve hatta baktım artık gün
kendimi 14 saat gibi bir şey kalmış ve
artistik jimnastik anlatacağım O gece
hiç uyumadım sabaha kadar çalıştım
herkesin yayına gireceğim olimpiyat
anlatacağım inanılmaz bir şey yani benim
için mükemmel bir durumdu ve bir şekilde
Oh yayına çıkarmayı başardı Ve hatta çok
güzel yayınlar oldu işte bu da oradan
bir görüntü Aslında böyle kabinden
anlatıyorduk yerinden anlatmıyorum o
zaman ama çok mutluyum yani her şey
acayip yolunda gidiyor yayınlar çok
güzel oluyor ve bu yayınlar hiç
beklemediğim bir şekilde çok fazla ilgi
gördü ve takdir aldım bunun birkaç
Sebebi Var tabii ki Bunlardan biri biri
daha önce bir spor müsabakasında hiç
kadın sesi duymamış birçok spor
izleyicisi var ya Tabii ki farklı geldi
bunlardan bir diğeri benim bu yerine
yaparken aldığım keyifle Tabii ki yani
sadece elime verilen metni okumak gibi
değil Burada por müsabakası anlatırken o
spor müsabakası ile birlikte iniyorsunuz
heyecanlanıyor sunuz yukarı Bu aşağı
iniyorsunuz bambaşka bilgiler
veriyorsunuz bu benim için mükemmel de
işte orada gerçekten kendi sesini
bulduğumu hissettim Çünkü burada sadece
yazılan metne okuyordum ve kendimden
birçok şey katarak kalbim ortaya koyarak
bu Yayınları yapabiliyordum Ama tabii ki
buna karşılık o dönemde çalışma
koşullarımız A çok iyi değildi Tabii ki
meslektaşlarına göre biraz daha az para
kazanıyordum biraz daha Aziz'in
yapıyordum ama yolunda öyle bir
ilerliyorum ki bunların hiçbiri benim
hiçbir zaman oğlum da olmadı o dönem ve
birazcık daha da artık bilinen bir
spiker haline geldi ve İstanbul'da büyük
bir kanaldan teklif aldım oraya transfer
oldum ve Oraya giderken de nasıl
özgüvenliyim her yerin yapabileceğime
inanıyorum işte ilerleyeceğim ve
inanıyorum başka işte gözümü futbola
basketbola diktim artık yani her ne
kadar artistik jimnastik atletizm farklı
branşlarda anlatımda yapıyor olsanız
futbol ve basketbol A geldiğinizde takım
bariyerlerle karşılaşıyorsunuz futbol mu
bu video çok kadınların sesini yapacak
bir spor değil veya basketbolun falan
gibi bu sadece Tabi yani Görünen bir yüz
değil En etme perde arkasında bir çok
kişiden duyduğunuz sözler bu tabii ki
sürekli etkiliyordu ve artık bu 7-8
yıllık bir spiker olarak da sadece bir
kadın sesle indir gelmekten de Çok
sıkılmıştım Bu arada Yani ben yayın
yapıyorum yıllardır hani ne alakası var
basketbol futbol neden anlatamıyorum
diye düşünüyordum ve
basketbol özetle anlatmaya başladım bir
futbol maçı anlattım ama bir yandan da
çok fazla iş yapıyorum Yani hem
muhabirlik yapıyorum Hem program
sunuyorum hem Seniz maçlarını
anlatıyorum hem işte Çeviri yapıyorum
Yeri geliyor sana inanılmaz yoruluyorum
çift mesai yapıyorum bazen üzerinde
sürekli bir baskı hissediyorum bu yüzden
bu böyle ve bir anda Tabii ki bu kalın
sesi olmaz Baskıda mücadele etmek
zorunda kalıyorsunuz bu şöyle birşey
yaratıyor insanda en ufak bir hatamda mı
sahip olduğum her şey kaybedebilirim
işimden olabilirim çünkü
erkek meslektaşları hata yaptığında
hoşgörüyle karşılanırken bir kadın
olarak ufak bir hata yaptığınızda
yayında işte işi bilmemekte
suçluyorsunuz Yetkin olmamakla
suçluyorsunuz Yani neler neler başınıza
gelebiliyor bu yüzden çok dikkatli olmak
zorunda değil hatta futbol maçı anlatan
anlatacaktım ertesi gün o gece panik
atak geçirdim Tüm bu baskılar sebebiyle
ve artık o kadar çok çalışıyordum O
kadar yorulmuştum ki artık Yayınları
yaparken çok zorlanıyordum ve keyif alma
Oranın çok düşmüştü ve sadece basketbol
özetleri anlatıyorum Çünkü bitiş çizgisi
orada görünüyordu basketbol özetleri
anlatacağım ve ardından bir basketbol
maçı anlatacağım fakat
bir gün yine böyle çok çalışırken
basketbol özetleri anlatımı çok fazla
takdir görmüşken hem kamuoyu destekliyo
Hem bu meslektaşlarımız bitter büyükleri
bunu çok güzel olduğunu söylüyor ama bir
gün yine bir yönetim geldi ve dedi ki
sen bundan e Okul adetleri
anlatmayacaksın Efendim dedim yani nasıl
olabilir böyle bir şey ya işte böyle
anlatmayacaksın Ben neden diyorum hiçbir
kesinlikle bir karşılık alamıyorum bir
cevap yok yani daha önce Yayıncılık
tarihinde özet anlatımı birisinin elinde
Muhtemelen alınmamıştır Çünkü aslında bu
kadar önemli sana bu kadar büyük bir şey
değil yani Genel Yayın ekranına
baktığınız zaman ama benim başıma gelmiş
ve burada gerçekten artık bütün o
kaçırdığım fırsatlar bütün başıma gelen
bu işi yapmak için yaşadığım tüm
olumsuzluklar kaçırdım sosyal
etkinlikler işte yorgunluğum hem
bedensel ve fiziksel yorgunluğun hem
Mental yorgunluğun üzerine Çünkü vardı
ve dedim ki bana artık yani şu an yarın
bana en sevdiğim en önemli basketbol
maçını bile verseler ben artık Bundan
keyif alamayacağım Bu benim için tam
tersi bir stres yaratacak o zaman Ben
şimdi neredeyim ya bu engel de düşün
gerçekten çok sert oldu çünkü her zaman
ve yapmak istediğini iyi bilen bir insan
olarak bir anda hayallerimi ne yapmayı
sevdiğimiz her şey kaybetmiştim ve
çalıştığım şirkette de Yollarımız
Ayrıldı tam bir hafta sonra da Panda ve
başladı ya gerçekten yer ayaklarımın
altından tamamen çekilmişti işte ne
yapacağımı bilmiyordum ama bir yandan ya
parmağımı kalacak enerjim yok içimde
Yani yeni bir ise başlayın
başlayamıyorum zaten Hanım var Öncelikle
de herkes gibi ben de Pizza
yapabildiğimi keşfettim evin içerisinde
daha sonra birazcık durup düşündüm
mecburduk Yapacak başka bir şey de yok
ama bir yandan hakikaten durmam
gerekiyor çünkü o zamana kadar gerçekten
çok çalıştım çok dedim de çok
yorulmuştum ve o da nam dinlenirken
birazcık tekrar o 400 metre engelli
koşan kızı hatırladım ve dedim ki acaba
ben bu engeli geçemeyecek yıkılarak ona
ihanet mi ediyorum aslında
bu ihanet etmediğini fark ettim Daha
sonrasında Çünkü orada farkına vardım
çok daha fazla şeyler oldu önce işte
yavaş yavaş kendi yapmayı sevdiğim
şeyleri yapmaya başladı mi Podcast
yerine başladım bu sporla ilgili değilde
tamamen Aslında kariyer arkadaşlık
arkadaşlarıma yaptığınız sosyal konuları
konuştuğumuz işte kariyer konuşuyoruz
Ben bazen başıma gelenleri anlatıyorum
Dertleşiyoruz böyle bir Podcast ve
Gerçekten çok başarılı oldu ve bununla
birlikte Ben yayın yapmaya gerçekten çok
sevdiğimi yeniden fark ettim birkaç ayda
geçmişti Bu arada ve hazır olduğumda
yeniden başka bir spor kanalı beni
anlatım yapmak üzere hazır bir şekilde
bekliyordu ve orada tekrar Spor
yayınları yapmaya başladım
ve İşte o tekrar bu yarışa dönüyorum öte
engellerde düşebiliriz kalkabiliriz
devam edebiliriz O devam etme arzusu
gerçekten çok güçlü bir Arzu ben de çok
fazla vardı ve çok işlevsel bir şey sizi
varmak istediğiniz noktaya çok rahat bir
şekilde bir süre biliyor ama bazen o
kadar yoruluyorsun o kadar
tüketiyorsunuz ki O engeli geçecek gücü
bulamayabilir sunuz o zaman da şunu
dikkat etmek gerektiğini fark ettim
biraz durup soluklanıp çevreye
bakabiliriz Çünkü
hayat 14 metre engelliyoruz Kesinlikle
değil kariyer yolculuğu Kesinlikle değil
çünkü orada bir kere bitiş çizgisini
görüyorsunuz önündeki engeli
görüyorsunuz burada önümüzü nasıl bir
engel var farkında bile değilsiniz Bazen
çok yüksek oluyor bazen derin oluyor ve
sadece üzerinden zıplayarak geçmenize
gerek kalmıyor artık birazcık daha
barklı Yollar aramaya başlıyorsunuz
bazen farklı kulvarlarda deniyorsunuz
bazen Engeli kaldırıp kenara koymamız
gerekiyor bazen birileri sıra yardım
ediyor bazen Siz onlara yardım
ediyorsunuz bunu böyle bir yolculuk
olduğunu gördüm ve kendimi bitiş
çizgisine gideceğim diye helak
etmektense koşmayı sevdiğimi yeniden
fark ettim Benden yapmayı çok seviyorum
ve bunu yapmaya da a Bu bir şekilde
devam edeceğim Ama bu yolda kendimi
tüketmem gerektiğini de öğrenmiş oldum
Çok teşekkür ederim Dinlediğiniz o